Obama men of hope februari 1968 i joined
the demonstration against the bombing of
big church Martin Luther King spoke to
us about justice is like a mighty stream
after the lecture I was completely taken
in by this mighty prophetic man and i
lost a book a book of poems I'm a child
survivor and poems were from a very
important because there were poems about
peace about justice and I look for that
book so i opened the work Big O and
there were all kind of states of paper
and I looked for the book so I went on
my knees suddenly the door opens and
Martin Luther King comes and he says to
me have you lost something I say yes a
book of poems he says let's look for it
he goes on his knees next to me and he
looks for the papers I want to say a
thousand things but I speak inside this
with him after a long search he says
unfortunately my brother we don't seem
to find it we shake hands I thank him
for helping to search for it and he
disappears out of my life and two months
later out of the life the world now in
the first week of President Obama I have
the feeling that we together will find
the movies